if you've played the game
an nfl player at your level do you watch
the game is it different for you to
watch the game than it is for an average
fan how does someone who's been there
watch the game i mean
realistically it just probably depends
on
what type of level of intoxication
okay
by the way
this is an intervention
these people here they're not here to
see the podcast we all love you and
we're here for you and we want the old
marshawn back
wait a minute this is the old marshawn
yeah man just older you probably know
when someone gets hit man that that one
hurt hell yeah most definitely and it's
usually the ones you don't see
but you know i don't know when you get
them piles that's that's usually the
ones that really
[ __ ] you up because then you got to
think you got maybe
maybe a thousand pounds worth of uh
people on top of you
and then you know depending on how
strong and what they really doing that
adds
another couple of pounds and
punches and eye doubt so that is
happening when because that's another
thing this is i'm just fascinated to
hear about this but when you were at the
bottom of that pile
and man you were on the you know when
they finally could
catch you there'd be 30 guys on top of
you and sometimes they just start to
build a house on top of that like you
know
let's build a 7-eleven here while we're
at it
and you're at the bottom what are they
doing to you are they really punching
you and stuff i mean there's a lot of
[ __ ] going on down there are people are
people saying stuff talk [ __ ] talking
all kind of shitty going on in there
it's like a whole like a little
community down here
that's fascinating to me i even bust a
couple knocks down at the bottom of the
uh
pile of coverton but you know it's just
all kind of [ __ ] there and people were
talking to each other and saying stuff
yeah like what's up bro what are we
doing after that you feel me after the
situation
are we getting out oh yeah all right
i'll meet you over there
i like that that
big pile the refs are trying to separate
you guys but while you're in there
you're talking about like you know i
found a really good sleepy time tea i
found
i found one that just knocks me out it's
really good yeah aka hennessy if that's
what you call your sleeper town
[Laughter]
you know a lot of us be having close
relationships too so hey man tell the uh
hey tell your cousin when i come back in
town i'm gonna highlight him you feel me
hey make sure the kids know i said
what's up family or tell mom tell moms i
said what's good about your family all
right i'm gonna holler at you in a
minute boy she oh she at the game she
gonna be in the back all right i'm gonna
pull up
this is all happening while you're piled
on top of each other that's fantastic